It happened an age ago.
She's talking about the shattering of the Elden
Ring. An entire age has passed, since then.
But when I recall, I see it true.
This character with four arms,
and pale, brittle skin, was a witness.
On a night of wint'ry fog.
In a shot surely inspired by the Lord of the
Rings, four shrouded riders flee the scene.
..and If you played the network test, you
might have even faced one of them. At night,
on a bridge, this exact same shrouded
horse and rider, can be found.
The Rune of Death was stolen.
But here's where things get interesting:
So runes are letters of a runic alphabet..and in
fantasy, they're often markings of great power.
The Elden Ring is actually made up of runes - its
tiniest pieces are a currency like Souls..but its
larger shards are called "Great Runes" , and
they are far more significant. Together, these
Great Runes of the Elden Ring spell out a Golden
Order for the world. Japanese descriptions call
it a Golden Law. A logic, for life to follow.
Now, this Golden Order is broken to its core..and
it all began, when the Rune
of Death of stolen.
So what was the Rune of Death,
and why was its theft important
enough to spark The Shattering?
Well..I think items in the Network Test
hold the clue. In Elden Ring, there's an item
called a Holy Pot, something you can throw at
undead enemies to prevent them from rising after
death. It reads "Incantations of the Golden Order
have been stored inside", "The Golden Order
has no mercy for those who trespass beyond
life's bounds", and its Japanese description
clarifies that "The Golden Law does not
permit the logic to live in death".
With the Rune of Death stolen from the Elden Ring,
nothing is keeping the dead in their graves.
That law doesn't bind undeath..not any more. Now,
spirits are found all throughout the Lands
between. Now, skeletons stand from their
graves. Even you, the Tarnished are
called "ye dead who yet live".
This lawless world has given rise to a group
called the "Golden Order Fundamentalists" who
try to enforce the old laws of the Elden Ring.
One of their spells is "Litany of Proper Death",
an incantation that prevents undead
enemies from coming back to life.
So this Golden Law can still be applied..it's
just not a universal truth any more.
Before the Shattering, the Lands Between
were ruled by Queen Marika "the Eternal".
Her being "Eternal", suggests that the Elden Ring
wasn't applying death to the Queen or her Demigod
children. However, now that seems set to change
- because the Rune of Death has been stolen,
And the demigods began to fall.
Surely it's no coincidence that only now, death
is being served to Marika's demi-god children.
A thief holds the Rune of
Death..and it's being used -
Starting with Godwyn the Golden.
In Dark Souls, all of Gwyn's children,
start with the same name prefix..you
know, Gwyndolin, Gwynevere..just so,
all of Queen Marika's children appear to have
names that start with the "God" prefix. So far
we know of two others: Goddrick, the demi-god
boss at the end of Stormveil Castle..Godfrey,
who we haven't seen yet, but who ruled over
his own age..and now..Godwyn the Golden.
A shadow looms over Godwyn - and it kind of looks
like a person holding a large weapon. When they
retreat, they take the light with them, and in the
darkness, emerging from the strangely shaped wound
on their back, a writhing force worms its way
around their body, and towards their eyes.
With this, Godwyn seems to live again after
death. As we mentioned earlier, undeath is
possible now..though we have no idea who he
serves. And while all this is going on...
Queen Marika was driven to the brink.
But she doesn't seem to have been killed.
Yet. We, as "Tarnished" are even able to
resurrect at her statues..suggesting that
she's still a force in the world, and that she
has an affection, or at least a use, for us.
In the scene to follow, her crown
is set upon an empty throne.
I say its hers, because this main
throne is surrounded by five..maybe
6 other, smaller thrones - likely
those of her demi-god children.
The throne itself is embossed with countless
depictions of the Erdtree. And we need
to talk about the Erdtree..because it's a symbol
of Queen Marika's power way more than the Elden
Ring is. The age before the Shattering
is called "The Age of the Erdtree", after
all [Source: Telescope description]. It's not
called the age of the Elden Ring. The Elden Ring
is just the source of the Erdtree's power - and
it's the Erdtree and Marika's family that seems
to direct that power, delivering Golden Grace
to certain folk of the Lands Between. But again,
we talk about that more in another video.
This scene is clearly meant to symbolise an
absence of that power now that the shattering
war has begun. And the last to leave this throne
room..is Margitt the Fell Omen. This is clearly
him - The main boss of Elden Ring's network test,
guardian of Stormveil castle..and now
perhaps..a servant of Marika's Royal Family?
The Elden Ring Twitter revealed that
"The cursemarks he bore from birth
were another ominous sign for the royal family".
This proves he was close to them, and explains his
name - Margitt was a fell omen for Marika's royal
family..a sign of the terrible things to come.
The Shattering ensued; a war
that wrought only darkness.
The Elden Ring was broken,
but by whom? And why?
So whoever broke the Elden Ring..hasn't publicly
revealed themselves, or made a play for its
power, even now. It follows then, that their
goal might have just been to watch chaos unfold.
The Great Rune of Death is just one part
of the puzzle - imagine how many other
Laws have been thrown into disarray.
Now, estranged demi-gods holding other
Great Runes [source: official website] are
warring amongst eachother. Why interfere?
What could the demigods ever
hope to win by warring?
This scene is so incredible..the absolute scale
of it. Under the shadow of a very sad-looking
Erdtree, besieging a fortress with statues
of Tree Sentinels..is a force familiar to
any who played the Network Test. These soldiers
and giants are seen all throughout Limgrave,
and their lion heraldry likely
marks them as warriors of Godrick,
one of Marika's demi-god children, and the ruler
of Stormveil castle. He's clearly waging war
against a city of the Erdtree - something
that would have been his former home.
According to the Elden Ring Twitter,
Godrick was "born a weakling child,
and coveted the strength of his kin". His "kingdom
is still at war long past the shattering"..and
he "clings to his ruined legacy, the ruler of a
husk wrung dry by war". Clearly he wields a lot
of power..but that power is waning - "Godrick's
claim as the rightful golden king is not wholly
uncontested. There are those who plot to see
his crown pass into more worthy hands".
Even after the shattering, powerful
individuals remain. Like these two.
The conqueror of the stars, General Radahn,
And the Blade of Miquella, Malenia the Severed
First thing here..very important..General Radahn
has a goddamn horse between his legs. Yup.
That is one sad fucking horse. I know
From Software tell some tragic stories,
but man..this is on another level.
Lucky for the horse, Radahn appears
to have gravitational powers..so
hopefully he's using these powers
on himself. Let me explain how I know
that: when you cast spells in Elden Ring,
the class of spell is revealed by the symbol
that pops up..and the symbol for gravitational
sorcery is revealed - here. And look..It's the
exact same symbol embossed onto his blades.
The purple glow between his blades is even the
same that purple gravitational sorcery gets.
For example, this is the meteorite spell. The
meteorite item description reads "meteorites held
the same import as stars"..and Radahn is clearly
capable of channeling that cosmic power.
Remember the first trailer, we ever saw?
Ohh elden ring. That which commanded the stars.
The Elden Ring commanded the stars..and
Radahn conquered them. I guess that would
make him a warrior of the Elden
Ring, right? In another video,
we'll talk about the age of cosmic power that
came before the Age of the Erdtree..but for now,
just know that this age did exist
long ago, before the Elden Ring
commanded the stars. This completes our rough
timeline. Anyway, back to the shattering.
These two were the mightiest to
remain, and locked horns in combat.
He hacks off Miquela's prosthetic arm..but she
snatches the blade attached to that arm out of
thin air, and uses her own body weight
to force it deeper into Radahn's flesh.
While doing this..she's muttering something -
an incantation maybe? I do think it's Miquela
who summons this orange lotus - it snakes in from
behind her, and probably teleports her away.
But there would be no victor.
We get to fight Miquela later on,
so obviously she survives this encounter
- though I'm not so sure about Radahn.
While the dialogue implies that neither one
of them lost this fight..remember - in the
first trailer, we see Radahn get struck
by this lance knight on horseback..so
perhaps there's more to this cutscene that we
haven't yet seen. For now, here's the finale.
And so, we inhabit a fractured world.
This character, is the storyteller. Wait that's my
job - anyway..on her right is a projection of her
self - a mirror image that shares her right eye.
What's fascinating about this..is that Melina, our
maiden..also has a closed eye with a marking.
Some people have pointed out that this marking
is on Melina's left eye..whereas this storyteller
has the marking on her right - but remember - the
Melina we see is an apparition. She appears out of
a blue, ghostly form..meaning she's actually
closer to this phantom storyteller..rather
than the real one. Therefore, the marking
might actually be on the right side
for both of them..if that makes sense.
Anyway..the world has been fractured. Even
characters..like Melina and the
Storyteller..are stuck in a sort of
limbo between life and death. Fractured.
Awaiting the arrival of the Elden Lord.
Unless of course,
Thou shouldst take the crown?
The last thing the Storyteller suggests
is that we might take the crown, and the title
of the Elden Lord. Now..I have two upcoming lore
videos talking about Melina's eye marking..what
the title of Elden Lord means..and so,
so much more. The lore of Elden Ring is
absolutely fascinating..so please do subscribe,
because I can't wait to share it with you. If
you're a $3 patron, keep an eye out - i'll be
uploading an early-access, audio-only version
of these videos in the coming days.
So if that's something you'd like to
see, consider becoming a patron..and
if not, subscribe, because those videos should be
edited in a couple of weeks. I'll see you then.